Friday was international Holocaust
Remembrance Day this was established by
the United Nations back in 2005 on the
anniversary of the liberation of
Auschwitz used to spread awareness about
the Holocaust the White House put out a
statement about this and that statement
notably did not mention Jews nor
anti-semitism which is certainly odd of
course there were other victims in the
Holocaust gays Romani disabled people
but there's no question that the
slaughter of six million Jews was the
central genocide by the Nazis and the
statement uses the word Holocaust so it
doesn't seem like they were referring to
all the killings of all groups but they
leave out who was the primary target of
the Holocaust per say you could say well
maybe presidents generally don't mention
Jews or anti-semitism in these
statements that's wrong both Democratic
and Republican presidents in the past
have mentioned Jews as the victims of
the Holocaust in these addresses and
there was a tweet sent out by
anti-defamation league director Jonathan
Greenblatt who called this puzzling and
troubling that Jews and anti-semitism
weren't mentioned in the statement and
this is where it gets really wacky even
the Zionist Organization of America
which is a very Pro Trump Jewish group
expressed disapproval about this now
here's where it starts to take on a sort
of weird tone and we have to see if
we're delving into the world of
alternative facts and concocted
narratives press secretary Sean Spicer
said that the statement was written by a
Jew so you know it's okay I guess take a
look at this the statement was was
written with the help of an individual
who's both Jewish and the descendants of
Holocaust survivors to suggest that that
remembering the Holocaust and
acknowledging all of the people Jewish
gypsies priests disabled gays and
lesbian is it's right I it is pathetic
that people are making on a statement
it's pathetic that people are pointing
to a notable omission and Politico is
saying they've confirmed that Russian
Jewish Trump a boy
Epstein was at least partially involved
in the writing of this but that also
could just be backpedal I mean what
difference does it make whether Boris
Epstein was involved in the writing of
this thing it sends the wrong message
particularly Pat as we've talked about
Trump's presidential campaign attracted
anti-semites in a way that no recent
presidential campaign has Trump took
many opportunities where he could have
denounced the anti-semitism and either
didn't denounce it or tepidly denounced
it this is not about Trump being
personally anti-semitic I doubt he is
his daughter is Jewish one of his
closest advisers his son-in-law Jared
Kushner is Jewish it's not about that
but it is again about now Security
Council member I can't believe I'm even
saying this Steve Bannon has a long
history of coddling implicit and
explicit anti-semitic nonsense on
Breitbart we have a number of different
anti-semitic and anti-jewish groups that
have come to Trump support this could be
yet another one of those wink wink nod
nod moments I'm not sure I don't think
it was anything deliberate I mean it was
a six sentence statement so I think if
they were to add Jews they may have felt
obligated to also add the other minority
groups that were involved which would
have added like five words yeah maybe I
mean it would have been it would have
been a whole nother sentence right would
have been one more I think what might
have been more offensive is the fact
that it ends by saying that Trump will
spread love and tolerance around the
world
what from his first week in office would
lead you to believe that that's hugely
offensive yeah and I'm sort of saying
tongue-in-cheek right I mean I've been
critical of just throwing around the
term offensive but yes it's actually
just factually wrong it's absolute
there's no reason to believe at all that
Donald Trump's presidency is going to
spread love nor tolerance and just all
very very weird and it's certainly
whether it was designed as a wink wink
nod nod to Trump's anti-semitic fans it
is allowing the sort of plausible
deniability that Trump is the so-called
Jewish controlled puppet or whatever
that we see parroted on alt-right and
other web sites so whether it's a
coincidence or not yes the implications
are different whether this
was just an oversight or a deliberate
wink wink nod nod either way it's
something that we should be concerned
about
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I liked the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing